[Music]
as a in a sense of wartime president I
mean that's what we'll fight we will be
invoking the defense production act
we're sending upon request the to
hospital ships are being prepared right
now the massive ships I have directed as
the president mentioned that the
hospital ships mercy and comfort be
prepared to deploy to increase the
nation's medical capacity and we have
also alerted a variety of filled and
expeditionary hospitals to be prepared
to deploy as well as needed
defense secretary on our show last night
talking about the deployment of US
military assets to fight this as the
president called invisible enemy taking
a look at the numbers now the
coronavirus in the u.s. all 50 states
total number of cases 7,000 663 total
deaths 115 worldwide one 214 thousand
eighty seven hundred deaths but total
recovered at this point eighty three
thousand three hundred thirteen the Dow
taking a big dive today and then
recovering a bit the Senate obviously
moving forward with the House bill the
phase two if you look at the Dow just
one market obviously but the Dow Jones
since the president's election take a
look at that rise and then that dramatic
fall when the coronavirus hit let's
bring in our panel charles hurt opinion
editor for The Washington Times Marv
Elias and national political
correspondent of National Public Radio
and Steve Hays editor of The Dispatch
Steve we're looking at all the federal
government is doing we've obviously seen
this second phase the bill heading to
the President's desk and it seems like
more is on the way significant amount
more yeah look I think it's an
encouraging development you heard that
you heard the president described
himself as a wartime president because I
think that's what we need from the White
House and from the administration in
order to make up for some lost time you
need the federal government scrambling I
think in some ways to catch up to the
states and the kinds of measures that we
are now seeing the federal government
taken whether it's moving the military
ships to two places that could be bugged
out come I mean at least at least we're
preparing I'd like to see them now move
on ventilators
move on additional protective gear for
physicians health care workers and other
things to really make sure that the
people who are on the frontlines of this
are protected as they try to take this
on Maura I mean we should get our heads
around the fact that these numbers are
going to just exponentially go upload
this testing as this testing goes into
place in big numbers yeah and the
administration has been trying to
prepare people for that I mean we've
been flying blind unlike some other
countries we didn't test massively in
the last two months since it arrived on
our shores so people are gonna get
tested and we're gonna find out
hopefully how widespread this is and
it's going to be a shock on the other
hand once we know who has it it's gonna
make social distancing more targeted at
least we'll have the ability to do that
I mean that's what they were able to do
in South Carolina and in Singapore but
yes we're going to have a big explosion
and then it will also make the fatality
rate get smaller because we're going to
understand how many people have it and
how many people are dying but in terms
of the response I think you're gonna see
this rolling response today it was all
about paid sick leave free testing next
it's going to be about actual cash in
people's pockets yeah and just to put
that up Charlie in Phase two
expands paid sick leave and family leave
to those in quarantine or caring for a
family member with the illness offers
free Coronis bribers testing for those
without health insurance extends
unemployment insurance boosts food
assistance provides school meals for
children's whose schools have closed and
provides additional federal funding for
Medicaid but we're ready for phase three
as Mara mentions and that's really just
a check to all Americans you know Andrew
Yang left the race a month ago and he's
saying man there's my thousand dollars
my idea may actually come to pass we
don't know the numbers yet yeah it
really is kind of amazing when you look
around and you see these orders coming
from governments to to shut down
restaurants to shut down
you know gathering places of ten people
are more you know coming at the state
level or local levels you know it's kind
of amazing those people obviously are
that work in those environments are
going to be the ones that are gonna be
the hardest hit
and that's gonna be you know and that's
a very real thing you know this whole
time we've sort of been in this waiting
game and it's it's it's hard to do
because most of the stories that we read
about are stories about effects of
quarantine Xand effects of things that
have taken you know the steps that were
taken as sort of precautionary measures
as opposed to actual results of the
actual virus and this is particularly
true outside of places like New York and
Washington in rural parts of the of the
country and where you see that that
great report that we just had about the
about people purchasing guns and
ammunition what that is more than
anything it's it's a it's a very healthy
American indication that people trust
themselves to take care of themselves
and their neighbors more than they trust
governments whether they're the local
government of the federal government I
think the important thing at this point
wherever you are on your level of
concern about this is it's kind of like
the saying you know if you find yourself
walking through hell don't stop
and I think Marv is exactly right you
know anything that we do at this point
whatever wherever you are on the concern
scale whatever you can do at this point
to keep going to march through the bear
market to march through this stuff is a
good thing you know what we were talking
about not going to places with ten
people or more obviously Capitol Hill
has a few more than ten people just
getting word right now that Congressman
Mario diaz-balart has tested positive
for coronavirus after voting on Friday
March 13th he self quarantines not going
back to South Florida with his wife but
just passing that along something tells
me we'll get a lot more of these
positives as the tests continue panel
thank you very much